[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous mercredi 2 mais bienvenue
dans le 7-8 journal sur tv 60,18 le tour
de l'actualité locale en 26 minutes
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition favoriser les rencontres de
terrain c'est la raison de la venue à
trappes de marlène schiappa pendant
trois jours la secrétaire d'état chargée
de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes s'installent dans la ville
yvelinoise nous avons suivi ce matin son
arrivée dans ses nouveaux bureaux
le projet folie fait polémique à jouy en
josas un centre de formation pour les
réfugiés va bientôt ouvrir ses portes
trois cents personnes y suivront des
cours de français notamment un dossier
critiqué par le front national qui
réclame la tenue d'un référendum local
sur le sujet elle et précision à suivre
et puis vous avez sans doute vu ces
images dans cette cette décharge à
carrières sous poissy des hectares de
détritus jonchent le sol depuis
plusieurs années une association locale
vient de porter plainte auprès du
procureur de la république de versailles
nous recevons son président anthony et
froid dans ce journal
également tout à l'heure alexandra
maingot co porte parole de la france un
soumise à versailles et saint quentin en
yvelines à nous parlera de la fête à
maquereau un mouvement de protestation à
l'occasion à d un an de la présidence d'
emmanuel macron autre mobilisation celle
des cheminots de la sncf il continue à
leur mouvement pointillés contre la
réforme du rail porté par le
gouvernement est la grève reprend demain
jeudi pour deux jours les voyageurs à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines devons faire
face une nouvelle fois des perturbations
pour la ligne c du rer c'est un train
sur trois prévus demain du côté de la
ligne l du transilien un train sur trois
enfin pour la ligne u le trafic assuré à
moitié un train sur deux les horaires de
vos trains sont à consulter sur le site
transilien.com et je vous le disais dans
les titres marlène schiappa et attrapes
pendant trois jours la secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes
il ya délocaliser son cabinet
visites et rencontres avec des
associations et habitants vont rythmer
son programme ce matin marlène schiappa
s'est rendu au centre d'information sur
le droit des femmes et des familles me
cale et demi d'euros a suivi ce
déplacement un nouveau bureau pour
marlène schiappa la secrétaire d'état
chargée de l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes délocalise son cabinet à
l'hôtel de ville de trappes pendant
trois jours ça me choque pas
particulièrement ce que je suis pas né
dans mon bureau au ministère donc j'ai
connu d'autres lieux de travail je
connaîtrais d'autres sans doute après et
puis un bureau de ministères on n'y est
pas toute l'année on est bon coup en
déplacement au contact des gens premier
contact pour marlène schiappa une
rencontre avec les élus politiques
locaux
objectif trouver des solutions sur
l'égalité est pas là pour faire un tour
de promotion de l'action du gouvernement
je suis là pour surtout vraiment écouter
entendre ce que les gens de trappes
honte à nous dire ce qui peut être
amélioré et ce qu'on peut faire
concrètement pour changer leur vie
quotidienne moi c'est ça mon moteur en
matière d'égalité femmes hommes
mais de façon générale je crois que la
politique elle n'est efficace que si
elle a un impact dans la vie quotidienne
des gens le reste c'est du baratin
la secrétaire d'état s'est ensuite rendu
sur le terrain l'a visité l'antenne du
centre d'information sur les droits des
femmes et des familles
donc on reçoit toutes les victimes
d'infractions pénales que ce soit une
victime de vol d'escroquerie de viol
d'agression sexuelle marlène schiappa
s'est entretenu avec les employés
pendant plus d'une heure pour moi la
politique c'est de l'humain avant tout
donc c'est comment des gens recueil
accueille d'autres gens et parle avec
eux je pense que c'est le nom de nom
c'est bon pour le territoire de trappes
c'est bon pour le gouvernement je pense
que tout le monde a intérêt à jouer le
jeu
de présenter au mieux ce qu'il s'y passe
en toute honnêteté avec ce qui
fonctionne ce qui fonctionne moins
jusqu'à ce vendredi marlène schiappa va
multiplier les rencontres deux terrains
il visitera notamment ce jeudi 3 mai la
pépinière d'entreprises chrysalide une
marche dans le quartier des merisiers
est également programmée ce vendredi 4
mai au matin
j'accueille sur ce plateau alexandra
maingot bonsoir vous êtes l'une des
porte parole de la france un soumise à
versailles et saint quentin en yvelines
une question déjà pour commencer sur
cette démarche que l'on vient de voir en
essayant bien sûr de mettre les clivages
politiques de côté venir au contact des
des habitants pour un élu national
pendant trois jours pour un membre du
gouvernement est ce que c'est une bonne
chose une bonne démarche
alors oui on va pas dire que c'est une
mauvaise chose après venir à trappes je
pense que c'est un bon coup de com
médiatique qui est fait par la
secrétaire d'état chargée à l'égalité
femmes-hommes
nous ce qu'on aimerait savoir c'est
qu'est-ce qui va derrière quelle
décision pourrait être prise quels
moyens sont mis en oeuvre et le sens du
coût de ce déplacement en précisant
juste que des actions similaires se
déroulent en ce moment même en france
notamment le premier ministre edouard
philippe qui est en déplacement dans le
cher pendant trois jours il y installe
son son son ministère également pendant
trois jours alors on parle avec vous
alexandra magot de d'un événement samedi
prochain c'est la fête à macron allant
d'air ce nom d'événements qui peut
peut-être faire sourire il ya une
contestation contre l'action du
président de la république lancé par un
député de la france insoumise justement
c'est françois ruffin on est à quasiment
un an tout juste de l'élection d'
emmanuel macron à la présidence de la
république pourquoi faire cette
mobilisation
alors déjà je veux juste finir avec
marlène schiappa quand on sait que le
budget de l'état qui est
donnée pour l'égalité femmes hommes
c'est 0 0 0 1%
donc nous notre mot d'ordre sur cette
venue c'est moins de blabla plus de
moyens donc là on va enchaîner sur la
fête à macron donc c'est une journée de
contestation
festive solidaire enfin le but c'est un
combat social associatif syndical
politique
voilà c'est l'objectif chacun vient avec
ses revendications mais le but principal
c'est le refus du monde selon dacron le
refus que le président des riches
détruisent nos biens communs
notre système français qui est solidaire
qui est protecteur qui est humaniste
donc voilà pourquoi cette journée elle
s'organise qu'est ce que vous retenez
dès 1 an 2 d'emmanuel macron à la
présidence vous parliez de président des
riches
il est souvent taxé de ce nom président
des riches à mayol macron il a annoncé
par exemple dans le magazine forbes
vouloir supprimer l'exil
l'exit tax qui taxent justement les
entrepreneurs français qui délocalisent
leur foyer fiscal à l'étranger c'est que
le président des riches
emmanuel macron alors c'est le président
roh
oui pas que mais effectivement la
première chose qu'il a faite au début de
son mandat ça a été la loi travail xxl
donc la casse du code du travail
après il a demandé
la solidarité en augmentant la cg des
petites retraites
en baissant 5 euros d'apl et à côté de
ça on nous vend que enfin on supprime
lisf donc effectivement aujourd'hui
c'est un non sens social c'est une
politique de non sens social qu'on
dénonce donc là il va y avoir une
suppression de 120 mille fonctionnaires
et les contrats aidés vont être
supprimés la loisy l'immigration a fait
quand même beaucoup de bruit ou c'est là
une des lois les plus durs de la vème
république
donc c'est le président des riches oui
c'est le président du chômage c'est le
président de la droite la plus dure
effectivement il y apparaît dans les
derniers sont ya pas forcément un côté
politique ça veut dire au mouvement de
samedi
c'est à dire là
l'assemblement de toutes les toutes les
luttes qui vont se faire c'est pas
seulement politique a totalement c'est
associatif et même chaque individu qui a
quelque chose à dénoncer à reprocher à
ce gouvernement
nous on continue d'inviter tout le monde
si vous êtes disponible et bien le
rendez vous est pris venait à paris
samedi prochain on vous accueillera les
bras ouverts et le but il est là que
tout le monde puisse effectivement se
déplacer et porter sa colère porter
porter ses revendications
si on regarde le bilan des manuels
macron alors on peut voir qu'il a tenues
certaines de ses promesses au moins une
partie notamment je voulais parler
avez-vous de la l'ouverture à la de la
politique à la société civile
on peut citer des cas au gouvernement
jean michel blanquer le ministre de
l'éducation nationale agnès buzyn
ministre de la santé on a vu le cas de
marlène schiappa juste avant est ce
qu'on peut dire qu'il a il arrive fort
mais aussi les pratiques politiques
emmanuel macron alors
effectivement il a réformé dans un sens
après j'ai le titre emmanuel macron du
reportage le casse du siècle
donc il a fait ces avancées là mais il
n'y a pas que lui nous la france ont
soumis c'est pareil à une ouverture de
la politique qui est faite pour tout le
monde je ne suis pas encarté je ne suis
pas syndiqué donc chacun tous ceux qui
ont une conscience politique et qui
souhaitent se aller dans un mouvement
eh ben c'est ouvert et c'est voilà alors
si on revient sur la mobilisation de
samedi justement elle a lieu dans un
contexte social particulier ont parlé
tout à l'heure de la grève à la sncf
on sera aussi à quelques jours de la
mobilisation après cette mobilisation du
1er mai et des mobilisations qui ont
dégénéré avec des dégradations et
affrontements d'environ 1200 black
blocks
est-ce que ça dessert ça dessert la
lutte alors effectivement nous nous
condamnons toute forme de violence dans
le sens où le but de la france insoumise
et l'avenir en commencer une révolution
citoyenne pacifistes en revanche
ce gouvernement at ease et amplifie ses
colères quand on voit que le
gouvernement envoie deux mille cinq
cents gendarmes face à 250 à dist que on
envoie les crs dans les facultés face à
des étudiants alors qu'eux-mêmes
sarcosine faire le président sarkozy
n'avait pas osé le faire je au nous nous
condamnons
mais on comprend effectivement la dérive
autoritaire du gouvernement macron et
ben amplifie et entraîne cette
radicalisation effectivement une
dernière chose très rapidement françois
ruffin souhaite qu'il y ait un front
commun des contestations donc samedi
pour cette fête à mâcon je le cite il a
dit il faut qu'on arrête on arrête de
s'engueuler on voit bien que la
faiblesse des mobilisations jusqu'à
présent c'est peut-être là non capacité
à faire front commun et ski ça doit être
une force il fallu pour espérer un
rassemblement large samedi
alors ce rassemblement il a il commence
à s'opérer d'un petit à petit j'ai en
date chez en tête la date de marseille
le 17 avril où il ya eu
une journée de contestation de mouvement
intra syndicales politiques avec la cgt
et diverses autres syndicats on sait que
nous main dans la main donc cette
convergence des luttes
elle se crée petit à petit donc là le 5
mai ce n'est pas une finalité il va y
avoir d'autres envois à d'autres dates
donc là d'ici à fin mai jean luc
mélenchon de la nôtre porte parole l'a
rappelé ce matin lors de son interview
appel
un samedi d'ici à fin mai pour à nouveau
faire une journée de contestation
puisque le samedi ça reste ouvert au
grand nombre beaucoup de personnes sont
en grève à l'heure actuelle perdre des
journées de salaires donc le samedi ça
permet d'être rassembleur sur ce point
là merci alexandre avant goût d'avoir
été avec nous je rappelle que vous êtes
co porte parole de la france soumise à
versailles et à saint quentin en
yvelines
nous vous l'annoncions dans le 7-8
journal maurepas et coignières
souhaitent se rassembler dans une
commune nouvelle d'ici le 1er janvier
prochain une volonté de fusion qui ne
passe pas pour tout le monde à
l'initiative de dix élus d'opposition à
coignières une pétition a été lancée
elle réclame la tenue d'un référendum
auprès des 4500 habitants pour valider
ce rapprochement
le document aurait recueilli près de
1500 signatures
une mobilisation est d'ailleurs prévue à
partir de 19h30 ce mercredi soir devant
la mairie de coignières malgré
l'annulation du conseil municipal en
raison des soucis de santé de l'édile
jean-pierre sevestre un autre projet qui
fait débat lui à jouy en josas l'ancien
site de thales sera bientôt transformé
en centre de formation pour les réfugiés
trois cents personnes tous les 6 mois
devraient recevoir sur place notamment
des cours pour apprendre le français
ce dossier piloté par l'association
emmaüs solidarité est critiqué par le
front national et les explications de
nicolas kirillovitch grillage fermé
locaux vides depuis près de neuf mois
l'ancienne université thales devrait
rouvrir ses portes d'ici quelques
semaines pour se transformer en centre
de formation pour réfugiés avec le
soutien de la préfecture d'ile-de-france
et emmaüs solidarité 300 personnes
suivront des cours sur place durant six
mois
objectif leur enseigner le français et
faciliter leur intégration
professionnelle
un projet est allé en tout sur 9 ans
auquel s'est ralliée la mairie après
avoir préempté le terrain il y à plus
d'un an
on y adhère je dirais par par par
nécessité par obligation mais on y
adhère aussi parce que c'est un projet
qui nous semble avoir du sens nous
semblera du sens que de former que de
près former des personnes réfugiées en
france qui ont
qui bénéficient du droit d'asile de
façon à leur permettre de s'intégrer
dans les meilleures conditions dans la
société française dévoilée dans le
détail aux habitants début avril lors
d'une réunion publique le projet suscite
depuis des réactions entre inquiétude et
étonnement pour certains il est aussi
critiquée par le front national qui
réclame la tenue d'un référendum local
sur le sujet plus la proportion de ce
centre est assez inédite
ça va évidemment modifier le visage de
l'asile je pense que les premiers
concernés sont les personnes à la ville
mais exact et aussi les élus et les
personnes qui habitent versailles grand
parc parce que les infrastructures vont
être aussi sollicité sur l'ensemble de
versailles grand parc face aux demandes
d'un scrutin local la mairie assure que
le conseil municipal est légitime en la
matière et qu'un ancien référendum
n'avait réuni que 2 100 votants sur cinq
mille électeurs potentiels
le maire est également en discussions
avec les différentes parties pour
faciliter le suivi et l'évaluation du
projet les premiers réfugiés devrait
loger et suivre des cours dans la
verdure jova sienne d'ici mi juin une
visite des lieux est prévue au préalable
pour les habitants intéressés un mode
économie 174 postes de travail répartis
sur 1000 mètres carrés l'enseigne de
coworking stop and works a inauguré à
tout récemment son 7ème centre à
montigny le bretonneux situé près de la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines
l'ambiance se veut cosy le thème du
cyclisme a notamment été mise en avant
le principe de ce nouvel espace proposer
des solutions de travail flexibles aux
chefs d'entreprises mais aussi aux
télétravailleurs écoutez ses
explications au micro d'aurélie rond et
marion de tak
à ce jour on a majoritairement des
petites entreprises qui souhaitaient
s'installer dans un environnement
professionnel où on leur offre tous les
services nécessaires la réponse allait
phonique la gestion du courrier des
salles de réunion un accueil
personnalisé
donc on est plutôt sur des petites
structures mais pas forcément des jeunes
structures
il a deux ou trois entreprises non je
peux pas vous donner le nom mais qui ont
quand même plus de cinq ans d'existence
qui font un chiffre d'affaires tout à
fait honorable ils ont juste pas envie
de s'isoler dans un bâtiment où ils sont
anonymes des déchets à perte de vue
depuis plusieurs années la plaine
agricole de carrières sous poissy est
victime de déchargement sauvage
aujourd'hui la situation est très
alarmante les détritus jonchent le sol
sur 25 hectares des risques sanitaires
et également des risques écologiques les
habitants et associations se sont
emparés du sujet avec nous l'un des
représentants de ces associations de ces
associations pardon c'est anthony effroi
bonsoir mon sort vous êtes le président
de rives de seine nature environnement
l'association vient de déposer une
plainte sur le sujet auprès du procureur
de la république de versailles on va en
parler juste après déjà pour bien
comprendre ce sujet comment en est on
arrivé à cette situation
manifestement il ya eu un certain nombre
de carences un certain niveau autant
administratif que judiciaire et il ya eu
un laisser-aller qui a conduit à cette
situation qui est aujourd'hui
catastrophique situation qui remonte sur
plusieurs années pour en arriver à peu
près sûr vraiment trois ans mais avec un
accroissement considérable était dernier
où le volume a plus que doublé
quels types de déchets on trouve sur
place c'est principalement des déchets
du bâtiment du btp
donc manifestement des entreprises
spécialisées dans ces déchets en tout
cas quels sont les risques
aujourd'hui on disait tout à l'heure
sanitaire écologique il ya plusieurs
risques il ya beaucoup de matériaux qui
présente une dangerosité importante on a
des plaques d'amiante qui sont concassés
dont ils peuvent justement entraîner des
dispersions de ses paillettes d'amiante
et donc avoir un effet sur sur les
populations on a un certain nombre de
solvants aussi qui sont déversés comme
sa mère totalement sauvage en pleine
nature
donc tout ça on estime qu'il ya
aujourd'hui des incidences 1 /
évidemment l'environnement et puis aussi
probablement sur la santé des riverains
donc on souhaite que les services de
l'état s'empare aussi ce dossier et des
habitants et des associations telles que
la volt se sont emparés du sujet votre
association ça fait combien de temps
qu'elle est sur le banc ça fait plus
d'un an déjà qu'on a alerté
les différents pouvoirs publics on a
alerté le préfet des yvelines on a
alerté les maires des communes
concernées
les députés des deux circonscriptions
également concernés on a aussi proposé
un certain nombre de solutions qu aurait
permis dans un premier temps de
sécuriser la plaine et donc d'empêcher
les nouveaux apports malheureusement nos
demandes de tables rondes ont jamais
reçu une suite favorable et on n'a pas
eu vraiment beaucoup d'écouté de la part
ni la communauté urbaine grand paris
seine et oise ni l'ensemble des élus du
secteur
on verra après justement quelles
solutions peuvent être apportées sur le
sujet alors votre association a mené
deux opérations dites investigations
pour trouver des responsables de cette
situation la dernière avait lieu le
week-end dernier
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert sur
place oui on est un petit peu obligé
finalement de faire ce travail
d'investigation puisqu'à notre notre
sens ça n'avance pas suffisamment vite
donc avec des bénévoles
on s'est dispersée sur cet immense
décharge et on a recherché les
informations nous permettant de retracer
les producteurs de déchets parce qu'au
sens de la loi les premiers responsables
sont quand même les producteurs et les
ché donc ça nous a permis quand même sur
les deux opérations dans une identité
plus d'une trentaine
ce qui montre que s'il ya véritablement
une volonté d'investir investiguez
justement sur ce dossier et trouver les
responsables de ce trafic c'est possible
maintenant on souhaite que ça judiciaire
face la même démarche
nous en tout cas toutes les informations
qu'on est en capacité à récolter on les
transmet immédiatement services
judiciaires qui aujourd'hui en charge de
l enquête suite à la plainte qui a été
déposée le 17 le 17 avril et étudie la
loi sur le sujet que risquent les
et les responsables alors là on est
quand même sur un trafic
particulièrement important
compte tenu des volumes de cette
décharge est également de la dangerosité
des matériaux qui sont présents on peut
considérer que c'est une icpe donc une
installation classée pour la protection
de l'environnement qui est non
autorisées donc une icpe non autorisée
c'est un an de prison 75000 euros
d'amendé qu'on voit ce sont des peines
quand même assez lourdes auxquelles
s'expose justement les contrevenants et
c'est pour ça qu'on estime qu'il est
urgent aujourd'hui que la justice
intervienne dans ce dossier
cette démarche de la plainte pourquoi
elle était elle était devenue importante
elle était devenue d'aller elle s'est
surtout elle s'est avérée extrêmement
importante lorsqu'on a découvert
qu'aucune des collectivités n'avait
justement saisi les séries judiciaires
alors qu'elle avait été avertie depuis
plus d'un an de la situation donc dans
ce contexte on était obligé voilà de
porter plainte et on a fait savoir qu on
souhaitait aussi se constituer partie
civile de manière à pouvoir suivre aussi
l'anc est également le procès lorsqu'il
aura lieu si on arrive à identifier un
véritable réseau qu'est ce que vous
demandez que ça aille vite vous l'aï dit
la situation remonte à plusieurs années
ça sent aggravée depuis trois ans faut
que les choses aillent vite qu'il faut
que ça aille vite aujourd'hui on voit
que c'est pas du tout le sens que je
peux prendre les choses puisque la
communauté urbaine se lance dans des
appels d'offres pour trouver un
prestataire qui effectuera des études
pour évaluer le tonnage de type de
matériaux et les filières de traitement
qu'en parallèle à la suite justement de
l'intervention de bruno milian le député
de la circonscription qui a sollicité
justement l'intervention du ministère de
l'écologie
avait obtenu la part du ministère de
l'écologie est ce que ces services se
met encore travaillent sur ce dossier et
apporte des solutions en fait à la
communauté urbaine de façon à ce que
tout se vaut les maîtrises d'ouvragé
finalement enfin assistance plutôt à
maîtrise d ouvrage ne soit pas à la
charge de la collectivité et on voit que
malheureusement la communauté urbaine
d'aujourd'hui lancé un appel d'offres
qui va dans le sens on perd encore du
temps c'est beaucoup de procédures alors
qu'en réalité ce qu'il faut c'est
maintenant que tout le monde réuni ses
énergies on avance rapidement sur ce
dossier car faut-il le faire quelles
sont les solutions qui se présentent à
l'urgence est de sécuriser totalement la
plaine les arguments contenus est avancé
en me disant que parce qu'il ya des
camps de roms c'est pas possible on n'y
croit pas une seconde
aujourd'hui il suffit d'une volonté
politique les moyens sont peu coûteux on
en a proposé un certain nombre justement
dès juin 2010 n parle d'un million
d'euros pour remettre en état le terrain
est ce que c'est un chiffre minimiser
oui alors là franchement je pense qu'on
est bien en-deça de la réalité nous nos
évaluations s'approcherait plus quand
même des 5 millions d'euros on est sur
7000 mètres cubes de déchets
donc probablement plus de 10 tonnes dix
mille 10 mille tonnes pardon de déchets
à traiter
donc évidemment que ça va coûter très
cher ça va coûter très cher d'où
l'intérêt et la nécessité de retrouver
les responsables
lorsque pollueur payeur il faut en
l'occurrence que dans ce dossier ça
s'applique merci anthony et froides à
voir que vous êtes le président de rives
de seine nature environnement et on peut
retrouver toute l'actualité de votre
association sur son site internet
à qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran et
dans quelques jours c'est la journée
nationale des mémoires de la traite de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions un
rendez-vous commémoré chaque année le 10
mai à saint quentin en yvelines
événement est également suivi avec la
semaine de la mémoire de l'esclavagé est
la dixième édition débute ce vendredi
par une projection débat au ciné cette
d'elancourt dans le reste du programme
expositions spectacles journée sportive
une semaine organisée par un collectif
nous avons reçu l'une de ses
représentantes lundi dernier dans le 7-8
journal elle parlait notamment de
l'importance du devoir de mémoire
extraits ça fait partie de l'histoire de
la france qu'on le veuille ou non c'est
tout pays à des tranches d'histoire un
peu plus sombre et cette tranche un peu
plus sombre sans jeu de mots il faut
l'aborder
il faut l'aborder mais l'aborder avec
des éléments tangibles des faits
historiques précis et non pas juste du
ressenti et cette semaine de la mémoire
de l'esclavagé a débuté en avant
première aujourd'hui une exposition est
proposée jusqu'au 10 mai à la
médiathèque antoine de saint-exupéry à
voisins-le-bretonneux deux thématiques
panthéon de nos héros et la traite
transatlantique reportage de marion tac
exposés pour ne pas oublier au milieu
des étagères de la médiathèque plusieurs
affiches et livre retrace l'histoire de
l'exclavage de sa mise en place à son
abolition en 1848
d'autres travaux mettent en lumière les
acteurs qui ont permis la fin de la
traite des noirs
c'est en fait une exposition qui est
composé de différents personnages qui
ont lutté pour
contre l'exploitation contre le racisme
pour l'acquisition des droits civiques
et c'est parmi ces grandes figures des
femmes et des hommes
rosa parks célèbre pour sa lutte contre
la ségrégation raciale aux côtés de
martin luther king ou encore victor
schoelcher l'instigateur du décret
abolissant définitivement l'esclavagé en
france on se rend compte que malgré tout
ce qui a été acquis malgré tout ce qui a
été dénoncé et tout ce qui a été
combattue
il ya encore malheureusement énormément
de choses que les gens ne connaissent
pas brunet ce mal et donc nous avons
besoin de déconstruire ce racisme ces
expositions sont ouvertes à tous elles
favorisent l'image et les textes au
cours afin de faciliter la compréhension
auprès des plus jeunes je pense que
la génération future vraiment besoin de
savoir ce qui s'est vraiment passé
l'ignorance en commandite l'ignorance
est vraiment une grosse maladie aussi
qui peut aussi causer aussi beaucoup de
coups de garde ses oeuvres occuperont la
médiathèque de voisins-le-bretonneux
jusqu'au 12 mai afin d'honorer le devoir
de mémoire
en 2001 la france est devenue le premier
pays à reconnaître la traite négrière et
l'esclavagé comme crime contre
l'humanité
on referme ce journal en prenant un peu
de hauteur les avions du régime en
normandie nîmes n était à l'honneur le
week end dernier à toussus le noble
ce régiment est le fruit d'une
collaboration franco russe qui a fait
front à l'est pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale et a aidé au débarquement en
normandie l'association aeria story
organisait deux jours d'exposition de
conférences et de démonstrations de
machines volantes à nicolas d'andria
maryland yapi chinois une allure pas
très moderne mais un décollage
impeccable les stars du week-end ont
fait leur show à l'aéroport de toussus
le noble
certains de ses avions de la seconde
guerre mondiale ont été pilotées par le
régime en normandie niemen qui a
stationné dans la commune en 1946 1947
l'association aerea story voulait faire
connaître cette histoire aux yvelinois
ce sont des gens qui étaient courageux
qui était qu'avait de l'abnégation qui
était prêt à tout pour défendre leur
pays
il y en a beaucoup qui sont morts ce
sont devenus des héros et il faut que
les jeunes le sache
il faut faire passer ses valeurs c'est
un petit peu ça notre objectif
passionné d'aviation d'histoire ou juste
curieux
les familles étaient nombreuses à faire
le déplacement c'était l'occasion voilà
d'avoir du concret
de voir ces avions de près on a eu la
chance de les voir décoller se mettre en
route
et puis on a eu des conférences surtout
très intéressante et aujourd'hui et hier
un biplan de conception des années 30 un
yack capable de voler à 600 kilomètres
heure et un mustang américains pouvant
atteindre les 700 km heure des avions
historiques qui ont émerveillé petits et
grands c'est la première fois que j'en
vois on voit d'habitude je vends des
siens d animer j'ai pensé que ça
développement il se développe mais notre
culture générale et elle devenait
meilleur intéressé de voir ça intéressés
par l'histoire de normandie niemen de l'
aventure un peu d des pilotes et de
cette partie de l'histoire
le régiment de chasse normandie niemen
est toujours opérationnel sur tous les
fronts la france est présente avec des
avions plus récents les rafales c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
édition à consulter à nouveau sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 très bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]